[Musique]
bienvenue au cirque et des secours aux
gens fait déjà des caisses
le saviez-vous j'ai été indien
boulomanes preuves à l'appui je sais je
sais ce mini en gsm une tête à claques
vous dites aujourd'hui on serait un gros
qui font faire high five au nou camp
était plus jeune je sais que tôt ou tard
vous avez dans votre vie envié des gens
qui avaient genre un diabolo un bâton du
diable des bolas tous ces trucs de
cirque voulez regarder avec mépris à la
cour de récré au collège et pourtant
vous aviez envie de quand même un peu
d'être dans leur groupe
vrai ou faux vrai ou faux aujourd'hui
j'ai envie de tester les objets
d'équilibriste les objets où tu as une
chance sur deux quand on fait une heure
d'avoir une entorse c'est la règle ici
j'ai une description de tous les objets
qui m'entourent et un truc que je rêvais
de tester et je vais enfin le faire dans
cette vidéo c'est le mot nautique déjà
qu'est ce que tu as l'air cool sur un
monocycle désolé à tous ceux qui se
déplacent en monocycle mais les gars le
personnage de façon aussi que ce que
j'ai ensuite et ça pour un humain de ma
taille qui est pas non plus petit de
foot des échasses et là c'est un combo
parce que ça a l'air d'être marron
d'essayer et en plus de ça s'écrit pis
un mec sur des échasses a fait baver
je vais te slender aujourd'hui entre
temps il y aura des objets un peu plus
simple évidemment que vous connaissez
probablement je ferai peut-être même une
petite démo diabolo j'ai tout perdu
c'est bon et enfin mais qu on va marcher
sur un fil je vais faire comme les mecs
en short natsu parc lahaie m'énerve et
reliant fil entre deux arbres eux ils
s'amusent entre amis à marcher sur un
fil sors ton chien et ramasse sa merde
comme tout le monde et art et de marcher
sur un fil
avec tout le respect que j'ai pour ce
qui compte c'est ce genre de truc ya
quand même deux trois estime qu'ils sont
un peu ridicules les gars soyons
honnêtes vous allez approuver ou non ce
que je viens de dire avec l'image qui
suit du bouchet ce mec
regarde moi ce bolide quatre ou deux
endroits pour mettre ses pieds une
rotation parfaitement étrange un max de
charisme
[Musique]
je crois qu'on a fait le tour du premier
objet c'est rapide tu as vraiment pas
fait long feu dans cette vidéo allez
battant il est mignon fait partie de ces
objets pour lesquelles on a de
l'empathie ça les gars typiquement
pourquoi ça a été créé je veux dire
c'est pas très charismatique c'est pas
plus amusant que ça et en plus tu
risques une entorse c'est étrange ce
truc comme ces genres
le frère du mec qui a inventé le skate
qu'a voulu inventer un truc qui perce
plus que le skate mais il a échoué samek
les assiettes chinoises frères
surexcités là j'ai fait des petites
boîtes à l'origine des assiettes
chinoises est inconnue merci pour ce
résumé la production mais leur existence
est mentionnée dès le moyen-âge
elles deviennent un art de
divertissement à part entière sous la
dynastie chinoise des âmes en 206 avant
jésus-christ dès l'avènement du cirque
moderne cet exercice de jonglerie et
effectué à dos de cheval
il semblerait que record du monde était
atteint en 1996 la douche chine et par
david avec 108 assiette tour des ponts
jumeaux
est ce que la vraie première assiettes
chinoises elle est née d'un mec a fini
de manger et pour passer le temps il a
mis au bout d'un bâton comme ceci
lorsque soudainement l'assiette ou
renard sa mère le regarda elle était à
deux doigts de le punir de lui dire si
tu casses l'assiette stöckli ni avis
émis largardère de 10 ans obama venu en
millions d'euros
j'ai de quoi en faire quatre georges
suis pas capable d'en faire quatre mecs
les gars je voulais un truc c'est un peu
drôle
j en ai une et de deux elle est cassée
ils m'ont donné là c'est de casser ils
avaient peur je m'attelais champion du
monde n'a de 96 à côté de ça je vais
vous dire un truc dofus on s'amuse pas
du tout format 0 faire tourner une
assiette au bout d'un bateau 20 sur 20
franchement mec c'est pas mal
quoi ah vous voulez un spectacle de
squeeze le dire boulomanes les gars je
sais plus du tout fait romano lemm du
diabolo c'est qu'ils annoncent assemblée
où j'avais oublié ce feeling le nombre
de gars quand j'étais jeune que je
voyais faire du diabolo au parc là on se
connaît des météorites sur la gueule non
c'était des diabolos des gens nuls qui
ont pesé à côté de nous sans transition
up égal à diabo l'on ne présente pas
froisser truc de siècle plus répandue de
l'univers regarder voilà tu fais ça tu
t'amuses tu veux faire le beau gosse tu
tenais à faire ça bien la toupie la
toupie j'avais le faire à l'époque bon
diabolo pas besoin d'aller plus loin
vous avez capté la suite au les mecs
avec ça ils m'ont toujours vénère ça les
gars je suis désolée autant j'accepte
les gens qui ont des défauts autant les
gens qui ont des bolas c'est non je suis
peut-être extrême dans ce que je dis
c'est vrai regardez bien la dégaine que
ça me donnait
[Musique]
c'est dangereux
tu me prends des coups je ne respecterai
jamais quelqu'un qui manie la molasse
c'est pas grave mais jamais trop tard
pour faire tourner une ou deux assiettes
les gamins en hausse à l'origine du
bâton du diable est incertaine le nom
néanmoins à l'origine chinoise
signifiant bas donc faire provient des
missionnaires occidentaux qui pensaient
que on s'en fout bâtons du diable c'est
comme les bolas j'ai du mal à être
impressionné
comment ça marche cette merde hop hop
c'est chaud bon mais compris
les gars si je m'en sors sans fracture
je pourrais continuer déjà je crois
qu'il faut commencer ouais voilà à s'est
passé un truc là dans le pantalon
non c'est impossible je suis en état de
choc
j'aurais préféré avoir un accident de
voiture
[Musique]
oh non moi qui voulait le vendre sur
ebay
youtube vous voyez bien qu'il ait cassé
vous pouvez me renvoyer un s'il vous
plaît merci beaucoup vous êtes vraiment
des frérots les gars on sait que c'est
casse gueule
on sait tous mais c'est dix fois pire
que ce que vous imaginez en fait je vais
vous dire un truc je suis profondément
déçu parce que je pensais grave avoir de
l' équilibre
[Musique]
bon écoute et mono cycle s'est terminé
là il nous reste du lourd ça s'appelle
le rouleau pour le réel intérêt du rola
bola
alors expliquez moi parce que risquer
une fracture gratuitement j'aimerais
bien ne vient pas du simple fait de
tenir dessus mais d'augmenter la
difficulté pour rendre la performance
encore plus spectaculaire par exemple en
réalisant du jonglage sur le rolla bolla
ou en empilant les rouleaux j'ai vu des
mecs faire ça à l'époque quand je
regardais le plus grand cabaret du monde
de patrick sébastien
tu a bercé mon enfance mon frérot et
arrête de couper la parole du coup tu
t'en la parole on dirait moi quand je
live c'est insupportable combien
d'humains ont mis leur salle pied sur ce
tapis avant qu'il arrive dans mon studio
un bon millier j'ai fait du skate j'ai
fait du snow j'ai fait le show c'est un
véritable crack
ok les mecs le vrai challenge manens
abonnez vous et dans un instant je vais
lancer une petite pub ne m'en voulez pas
je reviens juste après seraient dans la
même position a tout de suite relais
squeeze hausse les gars je suis je suis
trop franc maintenant je maîtrise de
petits il faut que je maîtrise le grand
aux mecs c'est un must lebel
impossible ça tu ne maîtrises après
avoir passé au moins 47 récréation avec
les mecs du diabolo la cie moment de
prendre de la hauteur sur voyez ce que
je veux dire il ya des cheveux à crolles
ça me dégoûte peut-être je suis à deux
doigts d'annuler les échasses mais d'un
autre côté j'ai toujours voulu voir ce
que ça fait de faire un mètre 90 alors
on va tester les échasses j'ai dit comme
ça ça lui mais lolo bienvenue au cirque
année squido ce qu'est ce que tu as dit
toi tu veux que je t'aime arabe la
gueule quoi au nom mais mec c'est
tellement humiliant qu'est ce qu'on fait
sur cette chaîne youtube
tu te lève la nuit pour aller pisser
dans son couloir lui c'est la première
fois de ma vie que je peux me prendre un
mur c'est énorme
oui un cambriolage j'arrive bon écouter
voilà voilà vous y pensiez tous voilà il
ya un truc que je voulais vous montrer
je sais pas si vous connaissiez on en a
parlé avec l'om et on est pas de même
hausser les boîtes à cigares
est-ce que vous avez déjà vu ça ça vous
dit un truc ou pas ma grand mère elle
regarder tout le temps le plus grand
cabaret du monde regarde tout le temps
patrick sébastien couper la parole aux
invités et des fois il y avait des mecs
qu'ils arrivaient sur scène est juste il
avait ça il faisait vous avez capté il
les échanger en l'air il ya du progrès
ça va vite gains bon ça m'a saoulé on va
marcher sur une boule plutôt les gars
j'ai envie d'essayer direct bon vous
verrez plus ma tête ce qui fait une
mauvaise chose
[Musique]
mais pas dessus mais en fait tu mets
pour ouvrir ainsi [ __ ] je pense si tu
vas d'un coup c'est plus simple alors là
ce qui a failli se passer ça allait
vraiment pas être drôle en fait c'est
plutôt satisfaisant de de jouer avec une
grosse boule
ça tourne mal c'est en train de mal
tourner la vie de ma mère
oh non mais combien de matériel je vais
[ __ ] les gars premier degré très
agréablement surpris de mon level en
grosses boules arrêtez avec votre esprit
là et tout ça nous amène à l'épreuve
ultime ac a marché sur deux voies non
non non je en train de péter toute ma
déco la arrête de t'échapper toi qui as
déjà marcher sur un fil je crois que la
dernière fois que j'essayais c'était sur
ce même truc et j'étais à l'école
primaire les gars pourquoi nous on fait
marcher sur un fil et qu'est ce qui se
passe là voulais pas juste nous
apprendre la vie ok les gars je tombe
sur la plateforme impossible mon truc
c'est clairement les moules les mecs
font des saltos sur des fils élastique
accrochée en haut de falaise moi j'ai
trois mètres de fil en métal et je fais
pas un pas eyadou il ya déjà du progrès
ap g faire un pas en plus haut
la technique latérale personne n'avait
vu celle là en fait faut juste rester
calmes et bouger avec ses bras arrière
mais je suis calme je bouge avec mes
bras je suis très calmes je bouge avec
les bras ou non dos reis quattro c'est
une consigne était absurde je me suis
même rappelé de 1 à 10 ans espagnol ça
je peux vous dire c'est au fin fond du
cerveau c'est pourquoi j'y arrive pas
parce que j'ai besoin de vous cette
chinoise ça canalise je vous jure
[Musique]
le cirque des cerises hausse va perdre
sa réputation si j'arrive pas assez
horrible je suis vraiment en train de
faire en vidéo ce que je faisais en ce2
dans le hall de mon école primaire
ça a changé du tout non et si jamais
c'est le plus vite de manière à salut
moi je suis né sur un fils je vais dire
j'arrive sèchement mais avant c'est
chaud je veux dire la terre plate quand
même c'est vraiment la pire des théories
du complot sa mère non
[Rires]
non
[Musique]
j'ai réussi c'est quoi j'ai en fait dans
l'autre sens tellement c'est easy
[Musique]
messieurs dames l'objectif final a été
atteint j'ai l'impression que c'est la
fin de cette vidéo
j'en ai chié mais c'était drôle c'est
intéressant de découvrir d'autres trucs
j'avais vu ça plein de fois dans ma vie
des trucs d'équilibriste et je me suis
demandé mais qu'est ce qu'il ya
d'amusant je comprenais pas qu'est ce
qu'il ya d'amusant a risqué une foulure
j'ai compris aujourd'hui j'ai compris
sachez que cet objet est l'objet le plus
dangereux que j'ai eus entre les mains
mais de très loin posé sur son mur il
fait un peu envie parce qu'ils aillent
au bout ça nous rappelle l'enfance quand
on faisait du vélo mais non ne cédez
jamais les assiettes un classique on ne
le présente plus toujours un plaisir je
suis à deux doigts d'en faire tourner
une amende en outre j'ai déjà une idée
de la suite on va tester des trucs très
précis un peu glauque bizarre mais j'ai
hâte de vous montrer ça voilà j'espère
que ça vous aura diverti merci les
squeeze aux félicitations pour
l'ouverture de notre cirque et à bientôt
[Musique]